i call this hearing to order
today we consider the president's
nominees
to head the cfpb and the sec
in response to the financial crisis the
wall street reform act
charged these two agencies with leading
roles
in restoring consumer investor
confidence
in our financial system richard cardrae
has been nominated to lead the cfpb
and has served as director since january
2012. prior to that
director cordray was chief of
enforcement
at the cfpb he has a long history
of public service including serving as
ohio's attorney general state treasurer
state representative and solicitor
general
well we'll hear more about the director
cordray
when senator brown introduces him
since his first confirmation hearing in
september
2011 director cordray has appeared
before this
this committee more than any other
financial regulator
during that time he has proved to be a
strong leader
of the cfpb he has completed
many of the rules required by wall
street perform
including a well-received final
qm rule he listens and has crafted
strong rules that take into account
all sides of an issue he has laid
the groundwork on or for non-bank
regulation
is brought to light the financial
challenges
faced by students elderly americans
service members and their families he
has taken
important enforcement actions against
banks
that took advantage of customers so i
asked what more can richard cordray do
to deserve an up or down vote i hope we
can
move forward with richard cordray's
confirmation
mary jo white has been nominated to be
a member of the sec and will be
formally introduced by senator schumer
as members of this committee have begun
to get to know her in the past three
weeks it is
clear miss white has an impressive
resume
as the u.s attorney for the southern
district of new york
jewish tough and respected as a lawyer
at the deb of wars
she has an understanding of the complex
issues facing the financial system
this is a critical time in the sec's
history
as it works on a range of rules and
policy issues
these include the focal role derivatives
credit breeding agencies hedge funds
standards for parker dealers and
investment advisors
corporate disclosures market structure
the jobs act and money market funds
just to name a few wall street reform
increased the
sec's duties to better protect investors
and oversee the market but congress has
not
increased the commission's budget enough
to keep
up i look forward to learning more from
miss
white on how she will approach these
challenging issues
as we mark the five-year anniversary of
paris jones failure this month
we are reminded why we need strong cops
on the beat enforcing an investor in
consumer protection laws
i'm pleased that that the president has
nominated marjorie white
to lead the sec and richard cordray
continue leading the cfpb both are well
qualified thoughtful leaders who bring
law enforcement experience to the job as
such
i hope we can move these nominees
through the committee in a timely matter
and now turned ranking member [ __ ]
for his opening statements
thank you mr chairman i appreciate your
holding today's hearing on the
nominations to lead the securities and
exchange commission
and the consumer financial protection
bureau both agencies are highly visible
complex
and were given very broad jurisdiction
by congress to act in their areas of
expertise
in addition each agency expends hundreds
of millions of dollars
every year to fulfill their respective
missions
cordray appeared before us last year at
his nomination hearings so we've already
had a chance to get to know him
and ms white has extensive experience in
our financial markets
both as a highly regarded us attorney in
new york and as a securities law
practitioner
i look forward to hearing from both
nominees
both the sec and the cfpb were created
after significant downturns in the
financial markets
nearly 80 years ago congress established
the sec to restore investor confidence
in our capital markets and to ensure
orderly markets for stock trading
and investing the cfpb was established
more recently as a part of the
dodd-frank act and is intended to sweep
all the consumer disclosure laws into
one entity
while leaving core prudential banking
regulation with the other respective
banking regulators
however the sec and the cfpb are
administered in quite different ways
when established in 1934 congress
decided to create the securities
and exchange commission based upon the
structure of corporate boards
congress set forth that the sec would be
comprised of five commissioners
each commissioner would be selected for
a five-year term and no more than three
commissioners
from any one party around this same time
congress also established the federal
deposit insurance corporation
again congress established the fdic with
a board structure
both of the sec and both the sec and the
fdic have survived nearly 80 years
and the board structure has provided
sufficient transparency and openness
so that congress and the general public
have a very good understanding of each
agency's mission and operation
unfortunately the cfpb lacks this
transparency and openness regarding its
operations
budget and intended activities it's
its intended mission the dodd-frank act
specifically elevated the director of
the cfpb so that he or she
holds unique power to determine the
agency's budget
and mission priorities without any
public debate or input from congress
for example in fiscal year 2012 the cfpb
spent more than 150 million dollars on
contracts and support services
which is more than the agency spent on
employees
this is nearly half of the money that
the cfpb received from the federal
reserve
last year there is no public accounting
on how these monies on contracts and
support services are being spent
to alleviate these and other concerns i
believe that the structural changes to
the cfpb
that we have recommended are essential
moving from a single director to a board
format is one of the important steps
that will bring about the transparency
and openness
that now exists with the sec
in addition the agency needs to be put
on the federal appropriations process so
that congress knows
how the monies are being spent
especially on items such as contracts
and outside services
and finally the prudential regulators
need to have more than just informal
input into the cfpb's policy
and rule making decisions with regard to
the president's recess appointment to
the cfpb last year
my opinion has not changed i continue to
believe that the recess appointment was
unconstitutional
the recent court case involving the
national labor relations board found
that those
recess board appointments violated the
constitution
since the cfpb recess appointment was
made on the same day
to me the same result should apply
recently members of the republican
caucus sent a letter to the president
objecting to the confirmation of the
head of the cfpb
unless these structural changes are made
to the agency
structural and other changes to the
agency are i believe areas where we can
work together
to improve the operation of the cfpb and
to improve accountability
mr chairman i look forward to hearing
from ms white and mr cordray on their
qualifications to head the sec and the
cfpb
and again i appreciate the chance to
work with you on these nominations
thank you senator carpol does anyone
else rush to make a short opening
statement before we turn to the nominees
for their testimony
mr chairman um
please withhold well we'll now
proceed to witness introductions oh
um senator schumer will now or introduce
ms white senator schumer thank you mr
chairman thank you and
senator crapo for holding this hearing
so quickly
it's my great privilege to introduce
mary jo white the nominee to be the next
chairman of the sec
mary jo was not born in new york but
like millions of others through the
years found her way to new york
found in new york her hopes her dreams
and a place to call home
miss white's long and distinguished
career as a public servant and is one of
the most
well respected and hardest-working
lawyers in the country
leaves no doubt that she's well
qualified to undertake the task that
awaits the next chairman of the sec
she is competent and dedicated tough and
fair
from 1993 to 2002 she served as the u.s
attorney for the southern district of
new york she remains the only women
woman to have held that position in the
200 plus years history
that the offices existed prior to
becoming u.s attorney for the southern
district she served as the first
assistant u.s
attorney an acting us attorney in the
eastern district of new york
from 1990 to 93. she famously put the
teflon don
john gotti behind bars and prosecuted
the terrorists
responsible for the 1993 world trade
center bombing
including ramsey youssef and the blind
sheikh omar abdul rahman
her case against the trade center
terrorists bears special mention
because it shows her creativity and
determination as a lawyer
she dusted off a civil war era seditious
conspiracy statute
to prosecute the case a move considered
risky at the time
but that ultimately proved successful
she also prosecuted numerous
numerous white-collar crimes including
insider trading
and securities fraud cases establishing
a track record
that leaves no doubt she will vigorously
pursue the sec's enforcement agenda
she's also had a long and distinguished
career in the private sector where she
earned a reputation
as one of the hardest working and most
well-respected attorneys in the country
she won a litany of awards from a
diverse group of institutions i'll just
name a few
in addition to the george w bush award
for excellence in counter terrorism
and the agency seal medallion given by
the cia
she also received the woman of power and
influence award
given by the national organization of
women and the sandra day o'connor award
for distinction in public service
now mr chairman most of the attention on
her personality is focused on her
toughness and her aggressiveness
and with good reason she apparently
indulged a fondness for motorcycle
riding
and despite her physical stature was a
fierce competitor
in the woman's basketball league in new
york
the same toughness she showed playing
basketball she will
show as sh c chair she will score many
points
and not commit too many fouls and if
anyone
if anyone questions her loyalty or
patriotism
i'm told that on those rare occasions
when she does relax
and take a break from putting terrace in
jail she likes to crack open a cold bud
but she has a warm and fuzzy side too in
2011 she was elected chair of the aspca
the american society for the prevention
of cruelty to animals
so all accomplishments and accolades
aside the moment of truth for me came
when i discovered that despite being
born in kansas city
and raised in virginia she was a
die-hard yankees fan
i hope that won't deter the senator from
ohio
uh in his in his deliberations
i know he hates the yankees what's your
website
okay it's some anti-yankee thing is his
call name
um anyway uh i'm confident she will
leave an indelible mark on the sec
and will continue the task of restoring
the public's trust
in the agency by challenging the agency
to live up to her own standard of
excellence
a standard unmatched by almost any
nominee who's come before this committee
during my time here u.s capital markets
have been and remain the envy of the
world
a huge reason why a huge reason why is
the reputation the sec has established
over the decades
for robust investor protection over the
last dozen years
the reputation has taken some hits enron
world comm and of course bernie madoff
in the 2008 financial crisis
but mary jo is the right person at the
right time
to build on the efforts of her immediate
predecessors and re-establish the sec
as the premier securities regulator in
the world
i wholeheartedly support miss white's
nomination to be the next chairman of
the sec
and i'm confident that after an
appropriately thorough vetting process
my colleagues will as well thank you mr
chairman
thank you senator schumer senator brown
will introduce mr cordray
senator brown thanks mr chairman my
understanding is rich cordray loves dogs
and cats too
so
we all do
i could i could show you my um i could
show you our
our dog franklin who we named after
franklin roosevelt and my daughter
commented after we got this dog that i
finally got the sun i always wanted but
i'll leave that alone yeah thank you
john
chuck you noticed also got iowa and ohio
mixed up which is
happens far too often in this
institution in idaho
ranking member crapo so thank you chuck
mr chairman thank you ranking member
[ __ ] thank you for for
holding this hearing and moving quickly
on this on september
2011 as a previous confirmation hearing
uh on
this same nominee and this same bureau
as my privilege to introduce rich
cordray
and introduce peggy and joined here by
their twins danny and holly
who are a year and a half bigger so good
good to see them
here today i've known rich cordray for
20 plus years his parents served as
strong advocates for people
with developmental disabilities he was
raised
to advocate on behalf of people who were
too often pushed to the margins
of our society and during his service as
ohio state treasurer he had been a
county treasurer he had clerked for
u.s supreme court justice kennedy and
during his time as the state treasurer
and later attorney general in ohio he
fought for ohioans who struggled to stay
in their homes he remains the right
person to head the consumer financial
protection bureau under his leadership
cfpb helped
service members and veterans and
military families understand their
benefits
he's helped students plan for their
futures and has helped baby boomers plan
for retirement
he's helped he's he's had a role a major
role in refunding some 425 million
dollars
to consumers who are victims of
fraudulent financial practices and
cfpb's handled more than 130 000
complaints from consumers in all of our
states
mr chairman we've we already had our
fight over the structure
of the cfpb a bipartisan majority in the
senate
created the cfp in 2010 to help ensure
that americans have access to safe and
transparent financial products and
services
including credit cards and loans but in
the united states senate a vocal
minority is pledging to hold up the
appointment of a qualified nominee
no one i have heard says anything less
about
rich cordray's qualifications that that
he is superbly qualified for this job
the legislation created cfpb is the law
of the land but some here want to
nullify the legislation
creating our nation's consumer watchdog
he's rich cordray has been supported by
ceos of ohio companies he's won praise
from ohio bankers
whom i've spoken with over the years but
for the first time in senate history or
actually it's the second time because
this happened with the same nominee in
the same bureau
just just over the last couple of years
and i asked the senate historian about
this
senators are blocking a nominee because
they simply don't like the agency that
he will lead
for cfpb to thrive it must have sound
leadership a leader who's able to work
with institutions and individuals
to prevent insidious schemes from
wreaking havoc on our communities and
our families
on our the citizens of this great
country now is the time to consider rich
cordray's qualifications not keep
fighting old political battles thank you
mr chairman thank you senator brown
i would also like to take this
opportunity
to submit a letter from our colleague
congressman cyrus who could not be here
today
but wished for his support to be known
we will now swear in the nominees
will the nominees please rise and raise
your right hand do you
swear or affirm that the testimony that
you are about to give
is truth the whole truth and nothing but
the truth
so happy god
do you agree to a prayer and testify
before
any duly constituted committee of the
senate
please be seated please be sure that
your written
statement will be part of the record i
invite you to
introduce your family and friends in
attendance before beginning
your statements mr cordray please
proceed
and members of the committee i'm honored
to be here once again
as the nominee to serve as the director
of the consumer financial protection
bureau
i'm grateful to the president for the
confidence he's shown in me
and for giving me the opportunity to
continue serving our country in this
role
if confirmed i pledge to continue to
carry out and enforce the law that
congress passed
to protect consumers and restore
confidence in consumer finance markets
over the past two years i've come to
understand how your committee exercises
great responsibility
that affects the lives of all americans
it's a pleasure to appear before you
frequently in my current role and we've
seen that our relationship can be
cooperative
and fruitful if confirmed i look forward
to working closely with you
to see that the people and families whom
we serve are treated fairly in the
essential marketplace for consumer
finance as you'd suggested mr chairman
i'm glad once again to have my wife
peggy and my twins danny and holly
with me here today like many of you i
commute back and forth from a long
distance to do this work
my family has been willing to make real
sacrifices without complaint
because they believe in what i'm doing
to serve our country
they know how deeply i appreciate their
steadfast support
from childhood my parents taught me the
value of work that seeks to improve the
lives of others
my dad frank who turned 95 just last
month
spent his entire career in programs that
served children and adults with
developmental disabilities
my mom ruth who died of cancer when i
was in college founded the first foster
grandparent program for developmentally
disabled in ohio
in addition to doing all the many and
various things that a mother does
to raise three fairly rambunctious boys
my approach to the role of director is
deeply informed by their influence
it's also deeply informed by more than
two decades in public service
i've served in the ohio legislature as
ohio's first solicitor general
as the franklin county treasurer and as
state treasurer
most recently before joining the bureau
i was ohio's attorney general
out of hard lessons learned through
these experiences
i developed a resolve to address the
kinds of financial difficulties
and challenges that confront our
communities i learned there's no such
thing as a one-size-fits-all solution as
we seek to aid those who want to do the
right thing
and when necessary to thwart those who
seek to take advantage of others
and i learned that creative strategies
to find solutions that can benefit
consumers and honest businesses which
share
many common interests when i became the
director of the consumer bureau last
year
i resolved to do everything in my power
to make the bureau accountable to
american consumers
to american businesses and to the
congress although our work is still in
the early stages
we have been busy in addition to
supervising the country's largest
financial institutions we've also begun
to protect consumers in markets that
previously received no federal
supervision at all
consumers now have someone looking out
for them as they deal with residential
mortgages
payday loans private student loans
credit reporting
and debt collection this affects
millions of people across this country
people who are your constituents as well
as the consumers we seek to serve
at the same time we're coming to a
better understanding about how to use
the other tools congress provided to
address the problems and challenges
facing consumers
we've adopted new rules for the mortgage
market to ensure that the excessive and
irresponsible practices that help
precipitate our nation's financial
calamity
cannot be repeated in the credit card
market we're implementing and overseeing
the extensive positive changes that
congress
enacted in the card act for consumers
who've been deceived by credit card
companies we've worked closely with our
fellow regulators to put 425 million
dollars
back in the pockets of 6 million
consumers
in the student loan market we've teamed
up with the department of education to
create products like the financial aid
shopping sheet so far we're pleased to
see that 644 colleges are voluntarily
adopting it
perhaps the most direct example of
addressing problems in the consumer
finance markets is our consumer response
function
to date we've handled more than 130 000
complaints
people have contacted us about specific
problems with consumer financial
products and services
ranging from improper charges and credit
cards to mortgage payments that were
wrongly applied
these consumers have come to us from
every state many of us have been
referred
by you and we thank you for forwarding
them to us
along with these initiatives congress
directed us to focus on the unique
problems that confront special
populations of consumers
assistant director skip humphrey and his
team have targeted the financial
exploitation of older americans
helping seniors get sound information
and advice about their retirement
finances
assistant director holly petraeus and
her dedicated team have identified and
are resolving distinctive issues that
affect our service members
veterans and their families so these are
the kinds of issues that the consumer
bureau is already addressing on behalf
of 313 million americans
of course there's much more to do on
each of these points and we're
determined to continue making progress
thank you mr chairman again and members
of the committee for the opportunity to
be with you here today
i look forward to your questions
thank you miss white please proceed
thank you mr chairman ranking member
crapo and members of the committee
it is my privilege to appear before you
today
as president obama's nominee to be the
31st chair
of the securities and exchange
commission before i begin my remarks
let me thank senator schumer for his
kind introduction
and i also want to introduce my husband
john white who is here today thank him
for being here today
and for his uh support uh our son and
his wife are law students and are
attending class today so they're
somewhere else today
thank you though there is no higher
calling in my view
than public service as the united states
attorney for the southern district of
new york
for almost nine years i worked very hard
on behalf of the american people
investigating prosecuting and punishing
those who committed crimes
from white-collar criminals to
terrorists regardless of the complexity
of the case
or the identity of the defendant we
always strove to do
the right thing and to vigorously
enforce the law
today i am honored by the prospect of
potentially returning to public service
as the chair of the sec to help carry
out its
essential mission while i served as
united states attorney
our office worked closely with the sec
prosecuting violations of the federal
securities laws
by both companies and individuals
through that experience
i became a strong admirer of the
expertise
independence and commitment of the
commission and its staff
i fully appreciate the critical role the
sec plays as the primary regulator
of our capital markets and as a strong
advocate on behalf
of investors today in the wake of the
financial crisis
and in the midst of implementing the
substantial legislative mandates
of dodd-frank and the jobs act the sec's
importance and scope of responsibilities
are greater than ever
if confirmed i will vigorously carry out
the sec's mission
to protect investors maintain fair
orderly
and efficient markets and facilitate
capital formation
this mission has a tripartite mandate
but the component parts should not be
viewed as in conflict with each other
it is the responsibility of the chair
and the commission
to take the long-term view balance the
objectives when necessary
and seek to fulfill all parts of the
critical mission
as with true when chairman shapiro was
here before you for the first time in
2009
this too is a critical time for the sec
although the worst
of the recent financial crisis may be
behind us none of us can be complacent
under the leadership of chairman shapiro
and chairman walter
the sec has made significant strides to
strengthen its examination and
enforcement functions
improve its capacity to assess risks and
enhance
its technology but fast-paced and
constantly changing markets
require constant monitoring and analysis
and when issues are identified the
investing public
deserves appropriate and timely
regulatory
and enforcement responses i am acutely
aware that the position
of chair of the sec carries with it
heavy responsibilities and many
challenges but if confirmed i will work
tirelessly
and do everything in my power to
effectively lead
the sec in fulfilling its mission let me
just very briefly
highlight highlight a few early
priorities
first i would work with the staff and my
fellow commissioners
to finish in as timely and smart a way
as possible
the rule-making mandates contained in
the dodd-frank act
and the jobs act the sec needs to get
these rules right
but it also needs to get them done to
complete these
legislative mandates expeditiously must
be an immediate imperative
for the sec with respect to rulemaking
and
rigorous economic analysis should inform
and guide the decisions that are made
although challenging particularly in the
quantification of benefits
in my view the sec should seek to assess
from the outset
the economic impacts of the contemplated
rulemaking
second if confirmed it will be a high
priority throughout my tenure
to further strengthen the enforcement
function of the sec
it must be fair but it also must be bold
and unrelenting investors and all market
participants
need to know that the playing field of
our markets is level
and that all wrongdoers individual and
institutional
of whatever position or size will be
aggressively and successfully
called to account by the sec strong
enforcement is necessary
for investor confidence and it is
essential to the integrity of our
markets
proceeding aggressively against
wrongdoers is not only the right thing
to do
it also will serve to deter the unlawful
practices of others
who must be made to think twice and stop
in their tracks
rather than risk discovery pursuit and
punishment by the sec
third the sec needs to fully understand
all aspects of today's high-speed
high-tech and dispersed marketplace so
that it can be optimally and wisely
regulated high frequency trading complex
trading algorithms
dark pools and intricate new order types
raise many questions
and concerns the experts and studies to
date
have not been consistent or definitive
in their observations and findings
about whether our modern market is
causing
harm or the extent of that harm to
investors there must be a sense of
urgency
brought to addressing these issues to
understand the impact on investors and
the quality of our markets
so that again appropriate regulatory
responses can be made
if confirmed i will work to ensure that
the sec has the cutting edge technology
and expertise necessary to enable it to
keep pace with the markets
and its responsibilities to monitor
regulate and enforce the securities laws
there are of course many other important
areas within the jurisdiction of the
commission
from money market funds to credit rating
agencies
from the appropriate standards and
regulations governing the conduct of
broker-dealers
and investment advisors when providing
advice
investment advice to retail customers
two how to make
public issuer disclosures more
meaningful and understandable for
investors
just to name a very few if confirmed i
would focus on these
and all of the many challenges facing
the sec in conclusion
it would be my privilege and honor to
carry out and help carry out the sec's
mission
thank you for considering me to serve in
this capacity
and for the opportunity to appear before
you today i'd be happy to answer your
questions
thank you for your testimony if any
member has any questions
for the record for either of our
nominees
i ask that you please submit them by
noon
on thursday march 14. i also ask
that the nominees respond to the qrs
quickly
so that we can move the nominations
forward
we will now begin asking questions of
our witnesses
will a clerk please put five minutes on
the clock
for each member mr cordray
south dakota's community banks and
credit unions
continue to raise concerns about
regulatory
burden how has the cfpb
addressed the concerns of small
institutions
while making maintaining effective
protections
for consumers and what additional steps
do you plan to take thank you mr
chairman
the visit to south dakota uh uh with uh
you
in which uh we met with local uh
financial executives and we have made it
a point to do that around the country i
believe we've met with uh
uh more than 40 uh community banker
organizations
or credit union organizations in the
last six months alone so we've been very
accessible to them i'll be speaking to
the
community bankers national conference
tomorrow and spoke to a credit union
conference
last week we also created at my uh
initiative a credit union advisory
council and a community banker advisory
council so we can hear regularly and
and specifically from them about what's
on their mind about their concerns
whether about us or about the
marketplace whatever it may be
and i think that that outreach uh and
the listening that we've done
uh has informed work that we have done
it affected our qualified mortgage rule
it affected our escrow rule affected our
servicing rule where we put into
practice what i have said here many
times the community banks
and credit unions did not engage in
practices that cause the financial
crisis
and the regulatory response should take
account of that fact and protect
and preserve their traditional model of
lending which is a very responsible
model and good for many communities
across this country like the community i
grew up in
in ohio and live
that's why it confirmed what steps
will you take to address potential
conflicts of interest
between your duties as acc chairman
and the past work on behalf of clients
as well as potential conflicts with
respect
to husbands work how will these steps
affect your ability to participate in
the commission's enforcement actions
or other sec matters thank you mr
chairman
before i agreed to be nominated for this
position
i detailed to the white house the
independent office of government ethics
and the career sec ethics official the
nature and extent
of my and my spouses and our firm's
legal practices
to be certain that there were no
conflicts that could be problematic
or limit my ability to function
effectively
as sec chair if i were to be nominated
and confirmed i went through a very
rigorous process of of my own and and
with these
uh parties uh to ensure that i am in
compliance with all
uh ethics uh and uh regulations and laws
and i'm very
uh scrupulous about these issues uh and
placed a very high bar on them and was
also focused in that process
very much on making certain i could
effectively function uh as the chair
i know the senate has received a letter
from the office of government ethics
concluding that i am in full compliance
with all
applicable laws governing uh ethics and
conflicts of interest
um well and i was also advised in this
process that while i have recusals
uh as do many nominees mine were not out
of the ordinary uh
in scope uh and the uh or nor out of
the ordinary for past chairman uh or
other commissioners of the sec
uh the career ethics officials at the
sec are quite experienced in managing
these
uh conflicts should they arise uh i will
also be very vigilant in
in managing them myself and making sure
that we are
scrupulously attending to any that might
arise
but i do not believe mr chairman that
the recusals the extent of them
will prevent me from fully performing my
duties in general i'm not
recused from any sec rule making matters
or policy matters and as to party
matters as as they're
known which primarily affects the
enforcement function of the sec
the scope of those recusals is also
quite narrow
ms white what approach will you take
with enforcement how will the sec
under your leadership signal that
wrongdoing
will not be tolerated and restore
confidence in the integrity
and the integrity of the u.s capital
markets
first i don't think there's anything
more important than vigorous and
credible enforcement
of the securities laws i think it it
must be done i mean to some extent
i think you convey that confidence to
the public uh by the deeds by the cases
that you make
by the uh deterrence that you affect by
your cases
uh and so i'll be very focused on that
throughout my tenure
and if confirmed i will meet with the
enforcement
division to review various of its
structures practices
and cases to make certain that that
happens
mr cordray what is your vision for the
consumer
financial protection bureau
mr chairman my vision of the
consumer financial protection bureau
really arises out of our work
and it rises out of the legislation that
congress passed
i think any agency needs to heal closely
to its governing statute
congress created us to protect consumers
in the financial marketplace
and to help make those financial markets
work more effectively
for the consumer public and for the
honest and responsible businesses
that dominate for the most part the
marketplace and deserve protection
against unscrupulous
uh competitors as i have said before i
i see our our vision in light of the
people we serve
they are to be most uh
direct about it they're our mothers and
fathers our sisters and brothers our
sons and daughters
everybody in this room and everybody
paying attention knows of people
in their extended family friends who
struggle with consumer financial issues
who need some help and support in
navigating complex financial markets
and to the extent we can deliver value
for those people who again are your
constituents and the people we serve
that's what we aim to do senator [ __ ]
thank you mister thank you mr chairman
ms white recently the sec has been
commended by the gao
for raising the bar frankly when it
comes to conducting economic analysis
and you actually
already answered my first question i'm
basically making a statement to you
right now but
the sec really has made major strides in
this area
and i appreciate what i took in your
opening statement to be your commitment
to continue this
and to even advance the agency's focus
on economic analysis is that correct
yes that's correct senator and if
confirmed i will also
there is sec guidance which i think has
brought about that enhancement that you
mentioned
and i'll be very focused on seeing that
as it operates in practice
oh thank you and this question is also
directed to you last year the financial
stability oversight council released a
set of proposals regarding money market
mutual funds
and many of us believe that that's a
responsibility that much
better lies with the sec would you agree
with that
it's money market mutual funds which are
very important investment products
i think are in the heartland of the
sec's expertise
and i think it is the sec's
responsibility as it
is focused on now and has been before in
determining
what additional reforms there should be
to that investment product
and if confirmed would you intend to see
that the sec takes prompt action in that
area so that it
takes the responsibility as it should
yes senator i would be and
my understanding is that that those
discussions are going on
uh currently thank you and and again
you've spent many years in the
securities industry in addition to your
husband as a prosecutor
your husband is a highly experienced
securities attorney i appreciate your
answer to the chairman's question
which was one of my questions as well mr
cordray
as you know the senate republicans want
to see key structural changes such as a
board versus a single director
of funding through the appropriations
process rather than direct access to the
federal reserve board and establishing a
safety and soundness check for the
prudential regulators
are you open to working with the senate
on these reforms to increase the
transparency and accountability of the
agency
we continue to be and i personally
continue to be uh interested in working
with the senate
to further develop transparency and
accountability of the agency there are
numerous
provisions in place now that we follow
but for example on the financial side
we're subject to a specific gao audit
which is unusual for agencies of our
finances we're subject to an outside
independent audit
we do a semi-annual report to congress
and i'm required to testify in front of
both this chamber and the house
on each of those reports so that's at
least minimum four testimonies per year
we have the federal reserve's inspector
general who oversees us
uh we also have been working toward
further fleshing out
you know you will recall that two years
ago we had zero personnel and zero
structure and zero process
we have recently uh added the
gipra statutory performance review
provisions into our budgetary process
and i think we could make more
commitments to you today than we could
have a year or two ago
and would be willing to do so in order
to improve uh
transparency further and make sure that
the congress has all the information it
needs and wants
about our expenditures as to our
accountability the congress
i always am accountable to you i have
found congressional oversight to be both
vigorous
and meaningful and it keeps us uh in
shape
and it keeps us on our toes and it it is
something we're very responsive to and i
personally have been responsible to and
appreciate the value of that
thank you and i appreciate our our
private conversations about the
importance of accountability and
oversight
and and your commitment to help improve
that yes
i also recognize that you can't say what
the white house and the congress will
ultimately decide with regard to the
issues
with regard to changing the structure of
the agency
but look forward to trying to work with
you to resolve those issues
and seek your support in helping us
resolve those issues
thank you finally
ms white again in your statement i
appreciate the fact that you mentioned
the jobs act
and placed those regulations as a top
priority
what timelines do you think you could
set for getting those regulations done
all of us up here i think are very
anxious to see these
regulations put into place as quickly as
possible
i appreciate the question um there's no
higher priority than i have
than moving the sec along frankly under
both the
frank act and the jobs act to get those
regulations out
as quickly as possible and i think you
can do them well and smartly and still
get them out quickly
i can't give you an exact date but i
guarantee you that i'm going to be
focused on that if confirmed
from day one phil thank you and i
appreciate your willingness to make that
a high priority
uh last question again to you ms white
with regard to the dodd-frank act the
sec made a public request for data and
statistics particularly on the potential
regulatory costs
to implement any potential changes to
fiduciary standards for broker dealers
and investment advisors
will you commit to reviewing the
findings of this request prior to
engaging in any rulemaking
absolutely i think it's a very important
area and i do commit to doing that
thank you senator greet thank you very
much mr chairman and uh
mr cordray and uh ms white thank you
very much
uh mr cordray one of the
responsibilities that you have is not
just to protect communities but to
ensure there's a comprehensive
regulation of
what used to be known as the shadow
banking system
um in fact one of the major defects that
we discovered to our chagrin in doing
dodd-frank and
the financial crisis that many of these
shadow banking institutions were
unregulated they were you know or
regulated by states et cetera and they
tend to
in retrospect sort of lead the standards
down to lower the bar lower the bar
putting pressure on regulate agencies
and now for the first time your agency
is able to
regulate these entities in fact you i
think done a remarkable job
you've recovered significant amounts of
money for consumers
but you're also setting us an even
standard between
the regulated industries that have
federal deposit insurance and other
federal protections and the unregulated
can you comment upon that role of the
financial bureau yeah thank you senator
that is one of the things that we've
been working hard to be doing and it's
one of the
very positive advances made in the
dodd-frank
law which is you can't regulate a market
effectively if you're regulating part of
the market
and the rest of the market is going
unsupervised and
not subject to any standards or
accountability and that's
very much what we saw in the mortgage
market leading up to the financial
crisis
and as you say that not only opens the
market to considerable
exploitation of consumers without any
oversight but it also hurts the
responsible honest businesses that are
trying to do things right
but that do as you say feel pressure
from unscrupulous competitors who are
not subject to the same standards not
subject to the same requirements
and that's just a model that can't work
and so the consumer financial protection
bureau was given the authority in
consumer finance markets to oversee not
only
banking institutions that are chartered
but also
unchartered institutions which has been
a very important part of our work
and frankly since the day i was
appointed which is when we gained
authority to
do that work has been a very high
priority for us
i know notice in this context the the qm
the qualified mortgage
rule is something you've worked with
with banking regulators etcetera
and frankly to the praise of many in the
bank industry
jamie dimon indicated they've done a
great job
quoting him and others have said that
too but it sort of reinforces the notion
which i think is not appreciated enough
that
your you function really uh in a way
to make sure that there is a level
playing field so that
traditional banking institutions
regulated institutions are not
under the competitive pressure of
unregulated that's
that's an important role it is an
important role it's one that
we're very mindful of and i think is
important
to the markets being able to function
effectively let me also commend you for
your
work with military personnel the office
of military
services headed by holly petraeus has
done a remarkable job
and that's another i think commendable
aspect of what you've done with your
leadership uh
you know protecting service men and
women from
foreclosure when they're in active duty
enforcing the
all the different regulations so i
commend you for that and thank you
um let me just turn in my remaining time
to
miss white first you can assure us that
in the rule making process
your prior employment would in no way
impinge upon your ability to participate
in rule making because the general
nature of rules
is that accurate i can certainly assure
you of that senator thank you
and have been so advised by the office
of government ethics as well
uh the next issue and it sort of touches
on
what senator crapo suggested can you
give us your top three priorities and
rules
you have a long long list of actions
pending
and it would be helpful to me to see you
know what's your priorities going in i
understand
when you get there and you get into the
details those priorities could change
but initially what are your priorities
well i have to say to that
senator that i uh and i realized i'm not
a naive person in terms of can you get
everything done at once
don't think anyone accuse you of being
naive
well i wasn't accused of that too i
think trust me but
but seriously senator i i think it is
and until i get into the sec if
confirmed
um you know i i don't have as much
detail on the work streams that are
proceeding
uh but it is my intention when i get
there to personally take charge of
uh assessing that and really and truly
trying to drive
all of the rule making as quickly and as
smartly as possible
so i don't have a rank order list yet i
just want to
get in there get it done get it done
smartly let me also just a a
sort of a footnote to your previous
comments which is
if there is an issue where you where
there's a potential appearance even a
conflict
what's the mechanism outside your own
individual judgment that you will avail
yourself to get guidance or to get
clarification essentially i will be
frequently consulting first i'll be very
vigilant myself as i think i have been
throughout my career
the sec ethics official and i have
already had
discussions assuming that i would be
confirmed about a very
vigilant screening agreement as well as
mechanisms to identify any possible
appearance issues as well
thank you very much thank you mr senator
crooker thank you mr chairman and
mr cordray once again your family has
been a great asset to you today your son
and daughter
are acting perfectly in the back and
even sometimes acts like the questioners
are asking intelligent questions
so i i do want to say that if you can
get
people dealing with consumers in the
financial world to act like they are
you'll do a very good thing for our
country and mrs white
during your introduction i had i thought
at first you had to be a leading
citizen from tennessee but thank you for
being here
um to you
i've already talked to mr cordray on
many many occasions
um you're going to be dealing with the
volcker
rule and we all know that prop trading
is out
but hedging and market making is still
something that's permitted
and i would just ask if you're if you're
committed to
making sure that we have really bright
lines there so that people
that the institutions that are affected
by volcker know the difference between
prop trading
hedging and market making i'm totally
committed to that and recognize
the importance of both the mandate to
bar proprietary trading
but also the permitted activities of
market making
as well as the hedging activities and
and again i guess i'm listing everything
i'm going to do the first day but if
confirmed i mean
that is one thing that i'm going to turn
my personal attention to
okay in the area of money market
funds i know we've had difficulties
getting to a place
i know you and i talked a little bit
about that in the office but
have you thought any about the floating
nav proposition have you given thought
to how you might want to resolve the
money market issue
i've given i have studied this issue i'm
not as i think i mentioned earlier privy
to the ongoing discussions
uh in the commission about it and
clearly i understand the risk that's
trying to be the systemic risk
possible run on the funds that's trying
to be addressed
by the discussions uh that are ongoing
but i'm also acutely
aware of the value of the money market
fund product
and so whatever is done we want to take
care that that is not
harmed by this i don't have any on
specific reforms until i get in there to
meet with the staff
and talk to my fellow commissioners you
know i don't have a conclusion on that
and the process that has you know it's
been a pretty long process there and i
know there have been some differing
opinions
do you view having commissioners like
this that represent
different viewpoints hashing out a rule
do you do you view that as being a
positive or a negative
that's a tough question i mean it's a
good question it's a very good question
that's a very good question i mean
clearly the uh
the structure the commission structure
which is designed to be bipartisan and
to bring in
as many different perspectives as
possible uh i think is a wise
structure the structure i operated under
before as u.s attorney i was more
autonomous
and i didn't mind having that autonomy
as well but i but i
i understand uh the strengths of that
of that structure obviously that that
requires you in a commission structure
to do a lot of talking with each other
which i think is quite healthy as well
uh and to you know bring people together
as much as possible
yeah thank you thanks mr cordray
i was i wouldn't ask mary jo this
because she's just starting but the
the f sock has the ability under
i think title ii to wind down a large
institution that poses a threat to our
country and
have a letter that's going out today to
everybody that's part of the f sock but
since you've been serving on it
is it your understanding that the f sock
has the ability to wind down an
institution
even if it's healthy because it poses a
threat to our country if it were to have
problems
or is it your belief that that
institution has to
have financial issues before you can
look at winding it down
or doing away with various lines of
business
i don't think that that issue has been
presented in the meetings that i've
attended over the past year
that we would take a healthy institution
and somehow seek to wind it down
it's been an assumption that the failure
of an institution or the impending
failure of an institution and and
therefore
uh the imminent weakness of the
institution would itself
uh pose a potentially systematic threat
to the uh
to the financial system uh and that's
been the basis on which
discussions have have proceeded and i
think that that's appropriate
so at present it's really been focused
only if an institution gets in trouble i
i'd like some clarification there and
the letter will come to you along with
everyone else who's on the board if you
could just look at
it mary jo at the right time if you
could do that that would be great
and on the the equity markets there's
been a lot of discussions recently and i
don't think any of us have fully
digested
this yet but there's a lot of high
frequency trading dark
pulls all kinds of things that are
taking place and there have been some
concerns about
that taking place to the harm if you
will of just
your everyday investors have you i know
you're committed to dealing with that
but do you have any initial thoughts in
that regard
this is one of the priority areas that i
didn't note in my uh
oral remarks and it is one that i take
away from my briefings
at the agency as a very very high
priority to
figure it out uh so that appropriate
responses can be made i mean certainly
there are concerns and questions that
arise from the high frequency traders uh
and
in our electronic market in general the
dispersed market in general but i think
in the first instance we need to know
what's happening and what the impacts
are and that again is
is one thing that i i do uh getting a
longer list of what i'm personally
driving i guess but but i'm very
very interested in focusing on that well
thank you both for your testimony and mr
cordray i do hope
i do appreciate the way that you've
dealt with our office and i would say
most people here and i do hope that that
over the course of the next short period
of time we're able to
figure out a way for the entity to
function in a manner that makes everyone
on both sides of the aisle feel
comfortable but i thank you both for
your
public service i thank the families for
being here
and i look forward to seeing you again
thank you senator senator
menendez thank you mr chairman uh you
know let me start off
by saying these are two exceptional uh
candidates
for these positions and they have
tremendous background and in the case
of mr cordray i certainly hope
that the ideological opposition uh
to the entity which received
a majority vote in its creation by
the congress of the united states
doesn't continue to be
the opposition to someone who is
eminently qualified
who has been fair who has been balanced
uh who has been transparent all the
qualities that you would want
in the director of an office and so
if if that is a new standard that
uh a majority will uh can now be
subverted by stopping a nominee
uh in order to subvert the agency uh
then that's a
that's a dangerous slope uh and so i
hope
that mr cordray's uh uh nomination moves
forward based on
his abilities and what he has exhibited
to us so far
uh and in the case of miss weich's uh
you know i know there are some who are
concerned about
her private sector uh experience i i
remember her as a very
tough prosecutor i used a different word
when we met but i won't do that here
uh and uh i said you could right
yeah but you know uh so
uh so these are two exceptional uh
witnesses having said that i do have
some questions
uh miss white um
i get numerous constituent letters uh
concerning the lack of prosecution of
wrongdoers
and basically
when i see the testimony of the attorney
general
before the judiciary committee when it
was act asked in this field
that the size of some of these
institutions are so large
uh that it does be this is quoting from
this testimony it does become difficult
for us to prosecute them when we are hit
with indications that if you do
prosecute
if you do bring a criminal charge it
will have a negative impact on the
national economy perhaps
the world economy so the question then
is
are are these institutions uh in essence
uh protected against prosecution merely
by their size
and understand that when in fact they do
violate the law that they'll have an
extensive fine and that would be the
cost of doing business
because if that's the case then i think
it subverts
uh the very nature of the honesty and
transparency
that we want to see in the marketplace
if the american people and investors
believe
that entities can do this largely with
impunity because they are so big
that they cannot you know be prosecuted
that at the end of the day
uh then how do i know that the system
is not being rigged at a time in which
i'm making my investments
so as the potential chair of the sec
give me your thoughts on what you would
do in that regard in terms of
when you found wrong doing assuming you
found wrong dooming what would you do
assuming you found wrongdoing i think
you proceed
quite vigorously against uh frankly
anyone that you find evidence of
wrongdoing on but but uh but certainly
financial institutions at the sec which
of course doesn't have the criminal
powers
those collateral consequences are not
taken into account before
charging decisions are made so that at
the sec
uh there's no institution too big to
charge and
on the criminal side it's it's they're
also in my view from my former life
institutions are not too big to charge
either but federal prosecutors are
instructed by doj
department of justice policy they have a
long line of factors to consider and one
of them
is the collateral consequences of a
criminal indictment to innocent
shareholders employees or the public
and certainly prosecutors should
consider that before proceeding
but that doesn't necessarily dictate a
no a no decision
so and if you were to be uh confirmed as
a chair at least to the extent
that the sec has powers of charging and
proceeding you would
vigorously do that when you found the
causes to be appropriate
absolutely senator secondly uh
in uh dodd-frank it's been reported that
excessive
compensation schemes provided part of
the fuel for the financial crash
in response i work to include a
provision in dodd-frank that would
require publicly listed companies
to disclose in their annual sec filing
the amount of ceo pay the amount of the
medium
company worker pay and the ratio of the
two now it seems to me while
the agency has struggled with immensely
more complicated rules
the sec has yet to take action on this
will you work
to uh follow through on this uh if
confirmed and make sure
that we get to the rules that uh
is called for under the law i will
senator
thank you very much thank you senator
joyance
thank you mr chairman
let me just say to both of you thank you
for being here i appreciate it
mr cordray if i could start with you
first
thanks for stopping by my office the
other day i
enjoyed the opportunity to visit with
you
when you took the oath that the chair
administered
as you know a piece of that was that you
would agree to appear before
any duly constituted committee of the
united states senate
so let me probe that a little bit um
would you be willing if asked to appear
before
the appropriations subcommittee duly
constituted of course
committee of the united states senate on
financial services
in general government to walk through
your budget document
and just answer questions about that
document
the spending habits of your agency
and would you be willing to do that
so senator uh we we have that the bureau
and i personally have testified
uh regularly i think more than 30 times
uh in the last uh two years
and under the laws that exists
what has been contemplated and what we
have done is
that i appear before this committee and
before the house financial services
committee
uh each time we issue a semi-annual
report so
twice a year in front of each chamber
each committee so that's four to begin
with
we've also let me just focus on your
budget though because
to some of us that's important and as a
former cabinet official i didn't think
that was a bad deal that i would be
called to account
before the senate and go through my
budget and justify it
and ask for permission to do transfers
and
i thought that was actually a good thing
and i think the senate appreciated it
house appreciated it would you do that
would you be willing to do that so i i
have been willing to appear in front of
the committees of congress and have have
done so
and if i'm understanding under the
current law this committee has the
opportunity to do that with me
if the desire were to have me do that in
front of a different committee
we could consider that that has not been
the structure that we have had
i think it's difficult for
among the banking agencies to suggest
that this should be the only banking
agency that would be appropriated
if there are measures that as you
suggest including
uh walking through and being subject to
more transparency and accountability
that would be
satisfactory uh to you and your
colleagues
we we could certainly consider uh uh
uh those things let me let me give you a
specific
example okay why we're concerned
and i think it's very very legitimate i
think we are elected to provide
oversight
in fiscal year 2012
the cfpb spent about 150 million dollars
on contracts and support services which
is more than what was spent on employees
that's nearly half of the money you
received from the federal reserve that
year
there's no public accounting on how
those monies
were used for contract services and
support services
would you be willing to appear before
that subcommittee and
answer all questions about that let the
subcommittee members
inquire about what that's about where
that money went and who got that money
uh and follow up with additional written
questions
we do that with with
every federal department really would
you be willing to do that
so so senator thank you for raising that
issue again the ranking member had
mentioned it in his opening
and i didn't get a chance to respond the
reason why we had so much money in
contracts rather than personnel in our
first year was that we did not exist as
an agency before that
much of the money was paid to the
treasury which we were part of for the
first year
and that we contracted with them for
services we continue to contract with
them for
to piggyback in their it service and
other things as we're building an agency
over time that is diminishing and will
continue to diminish
we also have published detail about our
specific contracts
uh what they are amounts and i've been
happy to provide that to this committee
let me if the notion to a different
committee
we could consider that yeah i'm running
out of time here
but this is only part of the essence of
our concern
and i think it's legitimate i think we
have a right as united states senators
to probe into this kind of information
because it's important that we be able
to tell our taxpayers our constituents
don't worry this money is being spent
wisely and thoughtfully and carefully
and we've dug into it and we can say
that that's what we're thinking about
and it's this committee that has had the
opportunity to do that and we are
quite welcoming of that and we
understand as i said at the beginning
i served in the legislature in ohio i
appreciate and understand the importance
of congressional oversight
i think it is a meaningful check on our
agency i don't take lightly when i sit
in this chair
and answer your questions or we deal
with questions for the record or we
brief your staff
we try to be as transparent as we can
and as we've grown as an agency with
we are able to do that more we are
completely committed to doing that
thank you mr cordray
senator brown thanks mr chairman um
ms white i have a number of questions if
you would try to do yes or no in the
first two or three because they're
they're pretty simple questions when you
were u.s attorney um
my understanding is you consulted bob
rubin and larry summers when considering
whether to bring charges against
financial firms is that correct
i actually consulted the deputy attorney
general who uh had
mr summers called me back i was asking a
factual question
did they did they reject the argument
that institutions could not be
prosecuted for the false to the fullest
extent of the law
i'd like to answer that yes or no but i
can't i mean essentially i was seeking
information
uh based on an argument that had been
made by the lawyers for
the institution that i ultimately
indicted
as to whether an indictment of that
institution would result in
great damage to either the japanese
economy or the world economy
and the answer that i got back is i
should proceed
to make my own decision which i took to
mean that
it would likely not have that impact
okay it i mean policy seems to have
changed you had a moment ago
said that um you talked about doesn't
did talked about doesn't consider sec
doesn't consider use the term collateral
uh collateral consequences to senator
menendez's question and in oh wait in
2008
the fed's general counsel called the sec
to urge the commission not to pursue
fall penalties against bailed out firms
that committed fraud
as a result institutional investors
pension funds that provide
retirement security for working
americans for example ended up with less
compensation
in the settlement on the new york times
affirmed that costs were shifted from
wall street banks to working americans
was the sec right to lower these
penalties back in 08
i think what the sec does do they don't
take collateral as i understand it they
don't take collateral consequences into
their charging decisions
uh but they do consider consequences in
their
remedies so that for example a corporate
fine that in effect would have
a grievous impact on innocent
shareholders is taken into account in
terms of remedies that they seek
i don't know all the particulars of the
example you're giving me so i can't
respond any further
than that okay we we know today the
banks are
considerably the largest institutions
are considerably larger than they were
only
five years ago the largest six banks in
this country now
control and senator vitter and i are
working on this and
some responses to the too big to fail
issue how control some 65 percent of
of gdp when only 20 years ago was
it was less than a third of that uh we
had senator menendez mentioned
attorney general's whole general
attorney general holder's comments about
cons
concerned about the size of the
institution and what what prosecutorial
action might do
yesterday arthur levitt one of your
predecessors currently a policy adviser
to goldman sachs
asked about when asked about attorney
general
holder's comments said i think he's
right there's no question
these institutions are very unlikely to
be the object of prosecutions
um you've said that bringing criminal
charges against corporations could harm
employees
by that logic you know a couple of
questions
first you do you agree with attorney
general holder and mr mr levitt
and if so aren't we creating by the
logic of
what you said about bringing criminal
charges
corporations harming employees aren't
aren't we creating a two-tiered system
where we exempt the biggest banks
because they have the most employees and
shareholders who could be affected
from criminal prosecution how do you how
do you sort of reconcile that
belief with your position that that no
firm is
as we say too big to jail in that way
understanding you don't have
criminal criminal authority but where do
you go with that
i think again it's it's a factor that
prosecutors are directed to consider and
not just the impact on employees and
shareholders innocent employees and
shareholders
but the public interest as well and so
you know i think we want our prosecutors
making decisions
you know in the public interest
obviously you don't want to have a
two-tier standard
for some institutions and not others but
i do think the
deferred prosecution instrument was
which has been used
a great deal on a number of companies
was designed to be tough in terms
of monetary sanctions monitors basically
everything but
at the charge itself that might cause
what the prosecutor may consider to be
negative and very undesirable collateral
consequences to the public interest
so i mean i think it you know i don't
think i don't think you should
and i don't consider it to be a rule
that uh or
even under the doj policy that therefore
you can't indict
you know anyone it's part of your
consideration it should be part of the
consideration
i think let me ask one other question
there is concern at least on
on this side of the committee i assume
on both sides of
your what people in this town called
revolving door
from the the firm to u.s attorney back
to the firm back to us attorney the firm
u.s attorney and
back to the furman and now this and
nobody questioned your integrity or your
aggressiveness or your toughness
um but just answer we need some
reassurance that when you have this job
that the culture you've come out of the
last 10 years i assume
both socially and professionally um will
allow you or perhaps make you better at
make that case
how would we ask answer this specific if
you can
what have you done over the last decade
that ordinary investors when you see the
the wealthiest in this country have done
better and better and better and most of
america hasn't gotten a raise
in the last 10 years what what have you
done that the last decade that ordinary
investors can look at and be assured
that that you will advocate for them
i i think to somebody said they have
it's true of anyone they have to see
what you do
in the job and in my case i think they
have a track record of when i was a
prosecutor well over the last 10 years
i've been a lawyer over the last 10
years
and when you're a lawyer you represent
different kinds of clients
and you are ethically bound to represent
them
to the best of your ability and i've
done that that does not change me
as a person it doesn't mean i embrace
the policy thoughts of any of my clients
in particular
and so i think the public investor
should know that i am their advocate
that i have a
very and i say the track record because
it's good to give them
something concrete to look at when i
think i was extremely exceptionally
aggressive uh against large institutions
against ceos senior executive types and
before i was that
i was in the private sector where i
actually started actually started in the
private sector so after
about the same amount of time in the
private sector i became u.s attorney
and had that track record i'm the same
person who in this instance if i'm
confirmed
the american public will be my client
and i will work as zealously as is
possible on behalf
done a great job one question for you
do you presently
submit your data to usaspending.gov on
how you spend your money
i don't actually know the answer to that
question senator but it's something i'd
be happy to explore with you or have my
staff explore with your staff
uh i will say again that we started uh
two years ago with uh just the
beginnings of an agency no i
i'm not critical i understand i'm just
asking a simple question
is everybody in the federal government
everybody is supposed to submit data so
that the american people can see where
the money spent
and so one way of answering senator
johann's question is
well sure we'll come discuss because
it's already been made public because
the american people have a right to know
where you're spending the money
and by federal statute as authored by
president obama and i
it is required of every agency to put
their information and their spending
on that site and so i'd love to have an
answer to that
and you don't have to answer it now i
will get you an answer and i have
explained to you and
my positions are very similar to senator
crapo in terms of the
requirements on this position i know
we're divided as a committee on that
and i won't spend any more time in it
but i will compliment you i think you've
done a wonderful job so far
in carrying out your duties and ms white
i i'll announce today
at the at this hearing that i'm going to
aggressively support your nomination i
enjoyed our visit
um the more i find out about you the
more i like you
and the more i'm proud that you have
agreed to accept uh to fulfill this
critical responsibility thank you thank
you thank you senator very much
senator tester well thank you mr
chairman and i just want to
start uh with you miss white if i might
uh
you've had a very interesting and
distinguished equi
career as as as senator schumer has
pointed out both as a prosecutor in
eastern
and southern districts in new york you
developed a reputation for
uh dedication and tenacity and i think
these qualities have contributed
mightily to your success taking down
some
uh pretty big dogs um you
sent one of the most reputed
mob bosses and john gotti to jail for
murder and racketeering
he led the charge as senator schumer
said against the blind sheik the
mastermind behind the 1993 world trade
center bombings
you're not only putting behind bars but
you connect the pieces to reveal that
this was not a single event
but rather an emerging trend one that
you saw firsthand you
your office also indicted osama bin
laden for his role in bombing american
embassies in east africa
at a time before most americans had a
clue who he even was
a major part of your success in the
southern district of new york and
prosecuting these
criminals was your ability to dig deep
to understand how they operated
the dynamics of their networks their
organizations and what their motives
were
these are some of the most dangerous
criminals that you put away
so first i want to thank you for what
you've done protecting this nation some
have questioned your toughness as a
regulator
whether you'd be able to hold
accountable those sorts of folks that
might have uh
you you might have defended in the past
and i would actually view your
experience
and expertise as an asset why because if
someone was going to commit a crime my
gut tells me that you might have a
pretty good idea where the body was
buried
it also tells me that given the list of
enemies you already have you wouldn't be
too concerned about wall street
so could you tell me miss white
how your expertise is a prosecutor
because this question has been asked in
many different ways this morning
how your expertise as a prosecutor will
help you with the
sec particularly as it relates to
enforcement
thank you very much senator i i think it
it helps i mean i have
extensive experience frankly from the
public sector as a prosecutor and the
private sector and investigating
various things and trying to connect
dots trying to go up the chain
to see whether there's evidence at high
levels
and i really look forward to reviewing
the entire enforcement
function and hopefully adding value
there from
my experience in both the private and
the public sector
if if if you um if you saw a wrongdoing
uh with the folks that you regulate
would you have any hesitancy whatsoever
going after him now let me let me let me
tell you where i'm going with this
uh senator brown talked about the
comments were made too big to jail
others talked about i think was you that
talked about the doj asked to consider
collateral consequences if i was a big
guy and wanted to take
the consumers for a ride i would design
my
my my bank my financial institution so
that
you couldn't prosecute him do you see
any reason out there why you wouldn't
prosecute
uh no regardless of how big they are
again from the sec perspective um
i do not okay um
you talked about in your opening remarks
uh the
uh your goals dodd-frank
jobs act as far as the rulemaking goes
um specifically
uh regulation a pledge plus which does
not have any statutory deadlines
uh could you just just talk to me about
and and we all talked about the first
day you're in you've got all this stuff
to do could you just tell me
how you're going to move that to the top
of the list no i i think it's uh
you know it again something that uh
whether a deadline or not
yeah and and again and the sec has
obviously been given a daunting list of
rulemaking to do
i you know i recognize that um but i
think uh
all of them have to be proceeded the
work streams have to be such
uh that they all get done uh you know
again i come back to maybe i'm not a
naive person but i
but you know i think it has to be done
some are easier to do than others as
well
uh and there's no reason to hold them up
good well i think that if
there's some attention paid to them
which i have the clear indication that
you are going to pay some attention to
them
that those rules will be forthcoming in
in
a much better order than they have in
the past
uh rich cordray first of all i want to
thank you for for what you have done i
think you've
you have done some good work i want to
talk about something that has been
uh pointed out to me from indian country
um in tribal communities um
and i believe uh there is a memorandum
of understanding with the navajo nation
at this point in time with you
these tribes have a really a unique
relationship and i should ask senator
brown
to see whether there is any indian
reservations in ohio or not but there
are many in montana
and president obama issued executive
order mandating
that agencies create and maintain a
formal consultation policy with native
american tribes i think it's very
important from my perspective
this consultation is critically
important as we deal with government to
government relationships
and and i appreciate the the outreach
cfpb has done
i just wondered have you initiated a
formal consultation policy
for native american governments
we are doing that senator and in fact
we've been doing a lot of
outreach to the tribal communities and
understand that
uh they have particular needs as
consumers and
deserve protection and as you say we
entered into a memorandum of
understanding
with the department of justice of the
navajo nation recently
we've done a lot of consultation with
them over the particulars of the cobell
settlement making sure that
everyone is village and vigilant about
potential scams and frauds around
that money coming to the tribal
community
and we treat the tribes as sovereign
entities and we're working with them
through our intergovernmental
affairs office if i could mr chairman
just a point
my staff who always know more in the
aggregate than i do as an individual
does inform me that the answer to
senator coburn's question is yes
we do submit information to usa spending
dot gov and if if you would we'll tell
him that but if you would pass that
along i would appreciate it
that's good i want to follow up on the
consultation yes
you said you're in process of developing
a formal consultation policy
or you have developed a formal
consultation policy we have
we have been in process of having
informal consultation and are working
toward
a formal consultation policy uh and uh
we'd be happy to follow up further with
you soon i would love that you'd like to
see
when do you anticipate or can you tell
me when you will have a formal
consultation policy for indian country
uh based on your interest in it i would
say
shortly okay thank you thank you very
much
thank you mr chairman senator to me
thank you very much uh mr chairman i
would like to direct my
questions to ms white thank you very
much for being here
thanks for taking the time uh to meet
last week
in my office i enjoyed our our
discussion and i appreciated that
um first just a quick follow-up on
the rulemaking regarding reggae in
particular of the jobs act and i know
from both your testimony today and our
discussion last week that
you've made it clear that that's going
to be a priority to get that done i
would just
want to underscore how important that is
now that we are almost a full year
past the adoption of the jobs act
and unlike some of the regulations
rulemaking
such as some that come from dodd-frank
the volcker rule being a case in point
that are incredibly difficult perhaps in
my view impossible
reggae is not like that it's really
straightforward and simple so i hope you
will
use the very simplicity as a criteria
for moving it up the list of priorities
so we could get that done soon
do you expect that to be something that
we could expect to see movement on in in
the
very near future i appreciate your your
comment on that and our discussion uh
and uh you know i won't predict a time
but i will i will say
that it strikes me as one that can be
moved and i'm committed to moving
everything as quickly as possible but
again as i said some are easier to move
and faster to move than others and that
would be one of those yes
at least from the outside looking in for
that question great thank you
um i'd like to to follow up a little bit
also on the discussions
about money market funds and you
mentioned earlier
that you recognize the importance of the
product
i wonder if you could just underscore
the importance especially to the
commercial paper market the
the marketplace that provides so much
liquidity and funding
that is such an important source uh for
investors
and the fact that there's no obvious
alternative certainly not in the short
run to the money market
funds as the vehicle through which this
this occurred do you agree with that
no i didn't i'm right yeah i do senator
as i said i haven't had the opportunity
to discuss
the internal discussion of the sec with
my fellow commissioners or the staff but
i have studied this issue
and i agree with your comments and you
again you alluded earlier to the to the
notion that since this is the area of
jurisdiction
and expertise of the sec that it makes
sense that the sec
would be responsible for the rulemaking
i make no secret about my view that the
fsoc has put
a lot of pressure external pressure on
the sec
and i worry that the commission might
consider doing something
in response to that pressure more than
response to the needs
of uh of the industry and and
i'm just wondering if you could assure
us since you'll have a seat on the fsoc
as well as being the head of the sec
your views on the importance of the sec
handling this yes i
it's a it's an investment product uh
it's where the sec has expertise and i
think
they should take the lead i think f suck
has been from what i've been briefed on
a very useful
very useful form for bringing the
different regulators together on
different
issues but with respect to the
rulemaking here i would certainly
like and expect to see it come from the
sec thanks
um furthermore with respect to money
market funds i think you and i share the
view
that we taxpayers shouldn't be at risk
to bailing out a money market fund
and uh if a money market fund were to
fail it should fail the investors should
bear that
that risk but taxpayers should not do
you agree with that general
principle well i guess i go back to to
the history in 2008
where you had the breaking of the buck
of the reserve primary fund and
treasury you know did step in to really
guarantee the share price which i
which was to stop a run on the funds you
don't want to get to a run on the funds
i think but i guess i you know the
reason that this is
such a significant issue is to uh try to
ensure while preserving the product that
you don't run that risk going forward
well right and i i know you're very well
aware
that that uh incident happened in the
context of a global financial meltdown
it was not caused by it was not
particularly concentrated in the money
market funds
there were more serious and acute
problems in other sectors as well
um i think that's important i also think
it's important to know
that there throughout 40 years this has
been a
an extraordinarily safe and sound
product but but here's a here's a
question that i have for you
specifically
is it your view that the role of the sec
is to make it impossible for a money
market fund to break the buck
i think it's the the role of the rule
making uh
to guard against uh while preserving the
product you know to guard against
uh the systemic risk i'm not trying to
be not responsive to the question but i
think that is
but that's different than making it
impossible for an individual fund to
break the box
it's probably hard to make anything
impossible but that shouldn't be the
goal of the ass my point is that the
goal
is to make sure investors are aware of
risks that they're taking
but that this is an investment that does
carry
some level of risk and that that's okay
i mean
there certainly is you know the risk
with a lot of products investment
products
uh kind of it's inherent in that again i
think you know the focus is on
preserving that but also dealing with
the possibility of the systemic risk and
run on the funds
okay well i see i'm out of time but i do
have some some follow-up questions i'll
probably say to you thank you
senator higgins
thank you mr chairman and uh to uh both
of our
witnesses here today thank you mr
cordray um i think you're doing a very
good job
and i look forward to supporting your
your confirmation
uh and i also want to say thanks to your
family your your wife and your your two
children here today
um we we appreciate your attendance here
and uh miss white i appreciate you
coming by
my office to meet me and i'm extremely
impressed by your record as a prosecutor
and i look forward
to you returning to uh to public service
and
in your testimony you mentioned
investing in technology
to keep pace with the markets can you
discuss how
a robust budget in this area for the sec
would help achieve that goal
and some of the issues pertaining to
what you see
uh the detriment would be without that
no i think it's it's
critical i mean today's technology is
not tomorrow's first of all so it's very
important for
the sec to be well funded for technology
and some of the
render continuing resolution as i think
folks know and
you know those a lot of those dollars
that we don't have would have gone into
technology so that
worries me i also think it's a great
investment of monies to hire more
experts uh market experts into this
space so we really
stay on top of what what is the present
day market the complexity of it the
speed of it
uh and so uh you know those those funds
are needed
thank you um the f stock has tasked the
office of financial research with
analyzing the potential risk
to financial stability if any are posed
by the asset management activities
and given that the sec is the expert and
primary regulator in overseeing the
asset management industry
would you share with me your initial
thoughts on how to ensure
that the sec plays a central role
in this effort thank you senator my
understanding is that the sec is in
active discussions with the
office of financial research on
precisely you know that subject
so that the sec's expertise uh and that
industry is brought to bear
and that's something that if confirmed
you know i also want to learn more about
okay um on uh on february 1st of this
year the sec's advisory committee
on small and emerging companies
unanimously approved a recommendation to
the sec
to initiate a pilot program to increase
the tick sizes for securities of smaller
companies and
the sec also hosted a february fifth
round table on the topic what
what are your views on a pilot program
that would increase this tick size for
small and mid cap companies
uh or stocks and then what's the uh
sort of the the pro and kind of of doing
this or not doing this
again this is something as i understand
is under active consideration
by the staff following those uh those
round tables uh
i think again i have to be read into
that before i reach a final conclusion
but but clearly it's a
it's a priority to focus on that issue
as well as just the small and mid-sized
companies in general
uh and to at least approach the issues
with
one size doesn't necessarily fit all and
we want
obviously more liquidity for these
smaller and mid-sized companies and
decimalization is a part of that the
spread the size of the spreads part of
that
and if um if that that pilot program
is going on is that correct my
understanding is
that the uh the sec is is
considering uh doing that based on the
recommendation of the discussion
and you know how big that would be i
don't whether i don't
be happy to follow up okay that'd be
good thank you mr chairman
senator moran mr chairman thank you very
much mr cordray uh
ms white thank you for joining us today
um
i i think in listening to senator toomey
and and my colleague from
from north carolina the topics that i
wanted to address with you ms white
have at least been addressed but i want
to add my emphasis
one of the issues that senator warner
and i have
tried to champion as startup companies
trying to make certain that we create an
entrepreneurial environment the united
states that
advances the the opportunities for folks
with an idea to pursue those ideas
and perhaps have a greater potential for
success and in the process of pursuing
their success
create job opportunities for americans
and
both the topics that uh that that seem
important to me
uh is this tick size issue that you just
were addressing
as well as the crowd source that senator
toomey pursued with you and
again you indicated in your testimony
that
you were
going to pursue rule making you would do
it as quickly as possible
i want to indicate how important that is
uh i i want to know if you have any uh
serious reservations about crowdsource
funding that would
suggest that you would uh would would
find
fault with the the process that
that congress has instructed you to
pursue
uh in other words is there a
philosophical or an economic reason that
crowdsource funding
a consumer protection issue that it
bothers you that would delay
uh if if you're confirmed and you're
making these rules would you be
uh opposed to this to this uh outcome i
and i senator thank you for the question
i i know that a lot of people are very
excited about this
happening uh crowdfunding uh the sec is
always concerned about
investor protection and should be and
is and i would be uh throughout my
tenure if confirmed
there are some protections built into
the crowdfunding mandates
uh and so you know i think that we want
to maximize those i also think we want
to be
sure that following these rules that may
come out
on on crowdfunding as well as some of
the others that we are
monitoring what is happening in the
marketplace so that if there is
whether to be fraud or some other uh
events that are occurring that needed to
be
addressed that were on top of it after
it's out the door and i know the
staff of the sec focused on that the
enforcement folks are
should that happen so that those
investor protections can be you know
taken care of and as you know after
after the rulemaking is completed but
but again i understand the priority that
uh that you that you put on it and uh
we'll we'll turn to that as well
do you know of any specifics at the sec
why
of concerns and why this is taking so
long any specifics about that
i don't senator john and let me ask you
the the i think it's a similar question
to what i've already asked but in a
different way
if you were a member of of congress and
this issue was before you would you have
been
supportive or opposed to this concept of
of crowd funding
i mean that's a that's a much harder
question for me uh to answer i mean i
think with respect to
frankly you know a number whether it's
dodd-frank or jobs act
you know what i might have done as a
legislator had i been fully read into it
i can't really answer but as a regulator
uh
it is my mandate to carry out that
rulemaking uh
congress has made a policy judgment uh
to do it expeditiously and
obviously as well as smartly as possible
well i would have been happy for an
answer to the
question about what you would have done
you did answer the question in the way
that i
was hoping that you would answer it
which is it's my responsibility to
implement the laws as congress has
determined
and i'm not putting words in your mouth
is that true you're not putting words in
my mouth that you said it better than i
did
uh and then on on tick size
um there are lots of ipos
access to capital that that see this as
an opportunity for
an improvement in that access to capital
and any any reservations
you have i i think you've pretty well
described your thoughts about this
with senator hagin i think the thought
of the pilot program
uh would be to sort of see how it works
with you know
various spreads in in various stocks so
that you get more
information before sort of finally
deciding you know what's optimal
um this is one again that i i need to be
read into further but
uh but at this point i don't have a
reservation the um
would you confirm that my understanding
is correct which is the sec conducted a
round table
it's now at the staff level uh following
that round table
they indicated like this is i guess the
question did they
indicate that there is going to be a
pilot program or that's not yet been
determined
i don't bel i don't know whether they've
indicated it publicly but clearly um
you know that was the discussion at the
round table it is under consideration by
the staff but i don't know that they've
said anything publicly about next step
well
they may have i just may not know it i
really do believe that we can
unlock lots of opportunities for
americans and job creation
and your job is an important one and the
the regulatory environment
finding the right balance matters
and consumer protection obviously is
important but also the opportunity to
create jobs for americans is exceedingly
important
and i would encourage you in both of
these instances to
to to act prudently but to act prudently
uh quickly
understood senator thank you thank you
senator warren thank you mr chairman
thank you both for being here
i'm not going to have any questions for
director cordrey
since you've already testified 12 times
cfpb officials have testified more than
30 times you've been an open book
i think there's been a lot of
transparency and you've won
widespread praise for both your balance
and your judgment but i do have
questions
what i want to know is why since the
1800s have there been agencies all over
washington with a single director
including the occ but unlike the
consumer agency
no one in the u.s senate has held up
confirmation
of their directors demanding that the
agency be redesigned
what i want to know is why every banking
regulator since the civil war
has been funded outside the
appropriations process
but unlike the consumer agency
no one in the united states senate has
held up confirmation of their directors
demanding that that agency or those
agencies be redesigned
and what i want to know is why there are
agencies
all over washington whose rules are
final
subject to the ordinary reviews and
oversight
while the cfpb is the only agency in
government
subject to a veto by other agencies
but unlike the cfpb no one in the u.s
senate holds up confirmation of their
directors
demanding that those agencies be
redesigned
from the way i see how other agencies
are treated
i see nothing here but a filibuster
threat
against director cordray as an attempt
to weaken the consumer agency
i think the delay in getting him
confirmed
is bad for consumers it's bad for small
banks
it's bad for credit unions it's bad for
anyone
trying to offer an honest product in an
honest market
the american people deserve a congress
that worries less about helping big
banks
and more about helping regular people
who've been cheated on
mortgages on credit cards on student
loans on
credit reports i hope you get confirmed
you have earned it director cordray
so my questions are for ms white thank
you very much
we've gotten a sense of you as a rule
writer
and i'm glad that's i mean as a
prosecutor
but i want to ask a couple of questions
around rule writing and actually i'm
going to start the same place many of my
colleagues have
and that is uh to talk about uh the
things that have not yet been done
in fact i'll just make a little note
here the consumer agency has met
virtually all of its rule-writing
deadlines the sec
has missed about half of them so far
but everyone's been highlighting the
rules that they want to make sure that
you focus on
i just want to draw a line under four of
them
that the sec has not yet written any
rules for
there are still no rules for credit
rating agencies
that took money to sign off on
risky deals that crash the economy
and still operate with big conflicts of
interest
there are still no rules from the sec to
deal with the derivatives
that were right at the heart of the
financial crisis
there are still no rules from the sec
to protect the counties and towns
that were cheated there are still no
rules from the sec
to require disclosure of ceo pay
relative to regular employees pay
so if people are going to talk about
priorities i certainly hope that those
are all
near the top of your list but one other
thing i want to ask you about rule
writing because it came up earlier in
the discussion is the economic analysis
or the cost
benefit analysis you know it's
fairly easy to measure
the costs of implementing a regulation
but what about the costs of under
enforcing the rules so what are the
costs
of people being cheated on mortgages and
credit cards
what are the costs when money launderers
are not
prosecuted what are the costs when big
financial institutions
crash our economy
so my question is how do you make sure
that when we're talking about cost
benefit that the costs not just of
enforcing regulations but the cost of
under enforcing those regulations is
also accounted for ms white
and i appreciate the question i think it
also relates to
measuring the benefits i mean i think
it's it's it's kind of it's a
it's a similar issue if not the same i
mean you know and
again one of the things that i if
confirm want to do first
also when i get to the sec
is to really bore into exactly how this
is being done uh you know i also have
the concern as we
all do even though in terms of having
our rules upheld by the courts which
that needs to happen as well
but i think we have to recognize that
there are uh
some benefits the cost of under
enforcement um
that have to be analyzed on their terms
in other words that you know
you have to say if you if you can't
quantify you say why you can't quantify
or or perhaps you do quantify
but you use a different parameter to do
it so i fully take your point
okay thank you very much i see my time
is up thank you very much mr chairman
senator merkley oh thank you very much
mr chair and
thank you to both of you for coming to
testify first i wanted to
accentuate the comments that senator
moran made over crowdfunding
that legislation here in the senate was
my legislation it was focused on the
fact that i go to
town meetings i've been to over 160 of
them
in oregon and people really are looking
for sources of capital to drive
small business so here is an incredible
need for small business capital and a
new innovative strategy for helping
provide
that source of funds and the rules were
supposed to be done
in january and we don't have a draft yet
so how can something so important to the
economy
so important success of small business
with folks on both sides of the aisle
saying the small business is really a
job in america how is it possible sec
doesn't even have a draft completed at
this point
well i mean i i go back to and this is
not
offered by way of excuse but they're the
rulemaking uh that the sec is
undertaking as a result of dodd-frank
and the jobs that
truly is daunting i mean it truly is um
on the other hand i think as i said in
my oral remarks
and my written testimony as well these
rules need to get out
and i need to figure out what work
streams additional worksheets need to be
put in place to do that thank you just
take my remarks as an encouragement that
something so important to the economy
deserves to be near the near the top of
the list
i want to turn to uh director cordray
director
the cfpb is the only banking agency with
decisions that are subject to the veto
of its rulemaking powers by another
agency
is is that is that correct fdic doesn't
have such a
veto occ doesn't have such a veal the
fed doesn't have such a veto
and that's my understanding senator yes
thank you and the cfpb is the only
banking agency with a capped budget
uh that that is correct okay
these are extraordinary then
measures related to the cfpb
and yet all we kind of hear about is the
cfpb
actually has fewer restrictions in other
banking agencies
why is there so much confusion among
some of my colleagues on this point
i don't know senator thank you thank you
something that that you have been
working very hard on with your agency is
assisting veterans and seniors and home
buyers with relevant financial
information
have the veterans seniors and home
buyers found that financial information
to be
of some use it's been a two-way street
i know that they have and i think that
there are changes that uh
assistant director petraeus has been
able to achieve such as taking account
of permanent change of station orders
and the kind of disruption that creates
in the lives of
service members and their families and
making sure that they have additional
protections for those
it's also the case that all of those
discussions have brought back ideas and
thoughts to us about how we can better
deliver more effective protections for
the unique circumstances of
active duty service members the strains
it puts on their family
and as as they become veterans and
graduate out of the service
uh peculiar needs that they have as
consumers uh that's been a high priority
for us
i want to thank uh the congress for the
work they did on the military lending
act
at the end of last year and we're
working with the department of defense
the other agencies to implement that
appropriately and effectively and we
will continue to to do that work and
it's important
focus for the agency well thank you i
can tell you
i'm hearing nothing but praise back home
from veterans groups and senior groups
for the type of work that you're doing
another thing that cfpb is doing is
research driven approach on financial
literacy
for example there's a whole host of
financial literacy programs which ones
actually work i understand you're
researching that consumer disclosures
what's
format for consumer disclosures abs is
actually of use to consumers
this is ongoing research i don't know
that you've you've published
findings yet but i think it's a great
idea do you
do you think it's going to have
considerable promise in helping us
understand better
uh how to uh provide financial literacy
or provide
consumer protections that that are at
the right place at the right
moment we are convinced that it
that it will uh and it's been part of
the
leadership of the consumer financial
protection bureau since we first
were created that know before you owe is
an important principle
and that we need to rethink some of the
assumptions in this field from the past
such as extensive long protracted
disclosures were somehow good for
consumers when in fact they often
defeated
consumers abilities to understand or
their willingness to wade through
we will be we have published a proposal
we will be finalizing
no before you open provisions for
mortgages later this year
we have uh voluntary efforts underway
with industry at the moment on credit
cards that we're pursuing
and we have no before you owe efforts on
student loans which are very important
and are part of our paying for college
module which is uh
now up on our website and we're going to
be promoting heavily over the next month
as people come to making
decisions about higher education they
and their family
families and they find those difficult
and confusing at times
thank you my time's up so i just want to
note that all of these things are making
families
stronger more successful that's
incredibly
important we shouldn't be measuring the
success of our american economy if you
will simply by gdp
but how many families have living wage
jobs and how many
enroll under your leadership in making
that happen thank you appreciate that
senator
senator schumer thank you mr chairman i
want to thank both witnesses i have no
questions for mr cordray i just fully
support your nomination and i do find it
anomalous
you're in the same boat as some of our
people on the
dc circuit people are opposing you not
because of you but because they don't
want
the body to which you are nominated to
function properly and it's
something brand new and i hope it's
something people will reconsider
i have two quick questions for mary jo
white
uh first on credit rating agencies as
part of dodd-frank there was a
bipartisan amendment led by senators
franken wicker and myself
and it gave the sec authority to issue
regulations rooting out conflicts of
interest and credit ratings
uh for structured products the amendment
passed on the senate floor with 64 votes
it was bipartisan ranking member crepo
voted for it so to ten other republicans
so it's now two and a half years later
and the commission hasn't used the
authority i understand the commission's
going to be hosting a round table on the
topic in may
it is my hope that the commission will
then quickly proceed to a rulemaking as
dodd-frank authorizes you to do
um will you make it a priority to
exercise the commission's authority
under dodd-frank
to address the conflicts of interest in
rating of structured products
i will and i think it's an extremely
important issue good well that's all i
can ask
uh second question as you know because
you and i have discussed this previously
i'm very interested in a rule proposal
before the commission
enhancing the ability of retail
investors to access proxy materials and
actually vote their shares we all know
that that doesn't happen
enough uh it's called the investor
mailbox proposal or the enhanced brokers
internet platform
can you state for the record whether you
support this proposal
there's a tremendous amount of support
for it and as we discussed privately
uh i it it's a very very good idea i
think the
uh the the rule the proposed rule is
still pending
uh but it's an excellent idea you'd make
that a priority i would i would thank
you
mr chairman the old maxim is quit while
you're ahead
thank you miss white and mr cordray for
your testimony
and for your willingness to serve our
nation
please submit your answers to the
written qr
pars as soon as possible so that we can
move your nomination into
untimely manner this hearing is
adjourned
thank you thank you
also on capitol hill this